[Music]
so
[Music]
hello
hi how you doing
welcome to this uh perfectly ordinary
stream where nothing strange is
happening and uh
there's just perfectly ordinary things
happening
good to see you it's been a bit
i
have been away
and uh
boy howdy do i have a lot to talk about
yes this is a perfectly ordinary stream
where nothing's happening and i'm just
gonna give you uh
the rundown
of all the other things that have
happened uh since last we spoke um
so hi yes actually this is a very
ordinary just update thing i've been
away i have been
uh
doing sound mix for in space with
markiplier um it's
it's so good
i i really um
i i gotta be careful with what i say
about it because i can't spoil anything
about it um but my god
it's so fun
it's really really fun um it's not done
yet it's almost here
uh it's almost here i can't give you an
exact time frame but it is in fact
almost here uh if you guys didn't know i
did put out some
trailers for the show i'm i'm sure you
guys have seen it uh obscurely named
trailers be they may but they are out
there and uh the show is coming together
beautifully
like if if you haven't seen
a heist with markiplier i recommend
going to see that and if you haven't
seen a date with markiplier prior to
that i would also recommend seeing that
uh just so you get an idea of what
you're getting yourselves into but
this is
uh
a step above
and i always like to
i don't know i don't want to say exceed
but i always like to improve on what
i've done in the past
and uh this is just like a real
testament to
just the the people that i work with and
like the skills that i have built in
myself and just like
oh god i can't say anything about the
show because it would spoil the show but
it's just
it's so good
and i'm not trying to pat myself on the
back being like good job mark you did
such a good job but just i'm really
excited for you guys to see it and it is
pretty much around the corner um i won't
no i'm not going to say it all why would
i say it all because that would be a
spoiler it would spoil it for you guys
you guys wouldn't get as much enjoyment
out of it if you actually uh waited to
see it
like if i told you everything now you
would not be able to appreciate it for
what it is so i'm keeping it all hush
mom is the word however i will say that
my next step right now is to work on the
official trailer for the show
uh the one that is going to really give
you a taste
of what's to come and oh i can't wait
for it i cannot wait
i'm just like literally as soon as i'm
done with this stream here i'm going to
go and work on that and
like that will be done it's going to
take a while to get that done because
you know obviously all the
final details of it need to be ready
before the trailer can be ready but oh
man if you enjoyed heist
you are going to
love space
and that's not me being
that's not just like me being like oh
yeah you like trying to drum up support
for it it's just this one is really
really really really
big
i think i mentioned a long time ago that
when i was uh when i was writing it i
wrote it much bigger than we had the
budget to do
um
and in this one
i have somehow
because when i said that i was like oh
no i got i gotta do rewrites so that it
can pare it down a little bit somehow
it's even bigger than when i originally
said
oh it's too big to make it happen and
it's somehow even bigger so that is
i just can't wait for it i really can't
wait uh but i've been away i have been
away for about um 10 days
i've been out of town uh working on that
and i have to do more so i've got to
leave uh
sometime in the near future to finish it
up but it is just the people that have
been working on it are incredibly
talented and especially the sound
engineer that i've been uh working with
just
incredibly talented because my my
directing style
is uh i i guess you would call it
unorthodox because when i'm on set
and i'm trying to describe what needs to
happen and i'm trying to explain what
the situation is number one i i explain
in way too much detail
i remember this moment from heist i
think i talked about it um in the stream
discussing it afterwards
that
there was uh someone from the art
department asked me where a plant needed
to go right and if you remember from the
show if you haven't seen it it's in a
deeper path that leads uh after the
zombie
the zombie
portion of it which uh just like
thinking back to ice man that was so
insane but it was that moment where we
come out of that little building after
you know the truck drivers like oh my
god the world's ending also i'm on fire
and then that we come out of that
building you know when we crawl through
those bushes for a convenient transition
to the next area
um
i the art department person come up and
say like oh where do you want these
bushes because obviously in my head that
doesn't or or in my head it makes
perfect sense to them it doesn't make
sense because the script i wrote was
[ __ ] but they were just like
where are those places go they you need
to walk through them i don't understand
so obviously they just want to know
where to put it and i could have done
yeah can you put it over there like in
the middle of the road and just like
you know stack them together so that you
can walk through it but no instead i
went okay so picture this right you just
came out you just came out of this
building after this truck went
and i described everything in like
terrible sounds it goes
and you're all freaked out right and
you're like i'm describing from you the
viewer what the first person perspective
is so you got to come through there and
what you're going to do is you're going
to dive through the bushes you're going
to go through the bushes
and then you're going to appear in a new
area that we're actually going to move
the camera over to the other side
of where we are and we're going to come
through them so when you put them you
got to make sure that you remember it so
that when we come out of it it'll be
perf and in no point in that entire
discussion of
you gotta come through and you'll see
you know at no point did i actually say
where i wanted the bush to be
so the person from the arts department
is looking at me like
so over there
over there i'm like oh yeah yeah over
there right in the street is good so
that's how i explain everything
to everyone in every shot
that we ever do
uh but because i want everyone to
understand why right they don't need to
understand why but i always feel like
it's better if people understand why i'm
about to tell them please put that bush
in the middle of that street so that we
can crawl through it
because then they would understand but
they don't need to know that but what
the beauty of what i was doing uh while
i was just down there uh for the sound
mix is i can describe that way i can be
like it needs to come
and it needs something
you
and what's amazing is this sound
engineer he's so good
uh that he knows what i mean and not
only does he know what i mean he makes
it perfectly and i'm it's like he's
hearing the sounds that i'm hearing in
my head and then putting them on the
screen i'm like oh my god he did the
sound mixing for uh heist as well so if
you're wondering why i sounded so good i
was all because of brad so you can thank
brad for that
yeah no it's uh
ah it's really something special i i
just i'm so excited because it's been
the labor of like
over a year of work like maybe even more
now that i think about it at this point
um
it's the culmination of a lot of work
and it's almost here and you guys can
almost see it
and to be here at this threshold of like
almost doneness is
crazy to me it's crazy to me so yeah and
and to clear up any i know there's
obvious questions like oh do you got to
subscribe somewhere no it's going to be
free just like heist was right on my
channel for anybody to watch
so
yeah
can't wait i can't wait
i cannot wait it is such a step up but
also it's been so much work but so worth
it because that's just what i do i like
i like putting my heart and soul into
projects like this because
for me like
it's it's more important to push
yourself and it's more important to
really like challenge yourself to do
something that you you may not even know
that you can do and i had a lot of
confidence going into it given that i uh
we did heist and i learned a lot of
things from heist and i i made a lot of
mistakes but i was able to correct it
you know so the show was still good um
but i took a lot of those lessons
learned into space
and uh man the show is so much better
for work but there was still like a lot
of things that i i learned from that
process
um
and i i will take into future projects
that i do
yeah
it's it's really cool um for those of
you who don't know what the the teaser
trailers i'm talking about if you go to
my channel
um
i think the first one was
everything has to end and it's just like
a video that has like a a black screen
and the other one is everything has to
uh begin
and uh
yeah they're just they're just little
teasers um but one of the reasons i talk
about that teaser because especially the
first one everything has to end
uh a lot of you noticed
not that it was not obvious but a lot of
you noticed that
there was a certain song that was uh
playing in that one it was a certain
song and yes you were absolutely correct
i said in the description but people
were still like i think that's
is that space is so cool yes that is i i
can actually what i'll do is i'll just
play you the trailer right now because i
have that power so i'll just i'll play
it for you right now you deserve it not
that it's
i mean deserve it you know it's just
you could watch it but you deserve it so
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i love that and you will recognize
that song as uh a an instrumental
of space is so cool
and it is so cool funny thing about that
is the sound mixer brad uh
before he signed on to do the sound mix
for this one and and it's really cool
because he was excited for it he was
really eager to do it uh which is an
honor because apparently the last one
wasn't hell for him to do but he's like
yeah i don't know how much time it's
gonna be or like
how much like it's gonna cost you know
in terms of work hours because and he
said i quote for all i know it could be
in space or something i don't know
what's going on in that guy's mind that
guy being me he's like i don't know
what's going on for all i know it could
be in space and the very next moment he
was handed the script and he read on the
cover
in space with markiplier and he's like
dad checks out it's just like it's
because doing sound for a space thing is
much more involved
no no no yeah definitely thank you brad
um oh let me let me go ahead and get you
the other one if you haven't seen this
one
uh this one's called everything has to
begin
um
and uh
this one was just
actually could use december 11th yeah
this was a while ago i guess but
i'll play this one for you
[Music]
we followed you to the end of the
universe
[Music]
people put their lives in your hands
all those colonists
that's on you sure
super cool
very cool stuff and and that was done by
uh
wes uh the vfx supervisor so aprice wes
for that one um and it's just like if
you don't know what these are these are
in relation to the upcoming show that i
am
going to be able to show you very soon
but not now uh
in space with markiplier which is a
sequel to um
i just got a warning heads up we
detected copyrighted audio in video in
your stream your stream may be
temporarily blocked uh that's it's that
was my video youtube i appreciate you
being so concerned i appreciate it but
uh
it's mine
it's my video
there's literally a big yellow warning
that's like warning heads up we've
detected copyrighted audio the artillery
has already started firing on your
location
yeah anyway so uh
yeah it's
it's coming soon
very soon and uh i will be making the
next trailer for it and you guys will
oh god
i can't why i can't wait i cannot wait
oh you guys are gonna love it you guys
are gonna love it
it's but if you haven't seen heist yet
go see it it is on my channel for free
you can go check it out uh you can check
out all the myriad of endings there if
you haven't seen a heist with markiplier
or a date with markiplier before
just search my channel for it or google
it uh you will find it if you haven't
watched that please do watch that i mean
i'm sure a lot of you have but if there
just so happens to be anybody uh who
clicked on this stream and doesn't know
who the hell i am go check that out it's
incredibly fun
but the other reason that i bring that
up is because
as in that first trailer there was that
instrumental of space is so cool which
you have bf nerd space is so cool i
guess i could play it for you here but i
might get a copyright strike of that um
definitely go check that out because
shmo yoho
emphasis on the yo
yoho
uh is doing a lot of music for
space and they are just doing an
incredible job like an outstanding job
uh like obviously the show is very big
so they can't score the entirety of it
um so they're they're picking moments
that are really important in the show to
score but they're just like they're
incredibly talented people
like just super super and talented uh so
one of the things also that i wanted to
play but i also might get i don't know
copyright strike i guess
uh in the in the link in the description
the top one it's the the animation that
i am talking about i meant to promote
this a while back when it first came out
it came out january 28th
but they did a music video a fully
animated music video uh that's kind of
in this series of cow attack they made a
new one and i highly recommend that you
check it out um i i'll go ahead and
maybe i'll just do it without audio i'm
probably gonna if my stream gets shut
down you know where to go there's a link
in the description so if i get banned
for this
please youtube have mercy
like do not
send the missiles after me i'm just
trying to help out
because this is so good
all right i'm gonna try this if i get
shut down
you know
who to call for help
okay
the van is just below the tree line
will be untraceable oh the reason that
i've always
[Music]
thanks for giving us a laugh old man
it's been
i don't know how you know what you know
old man but now would be the perfect
time for you to say goodbye to your
precious cow
[Music]
[Music]
never done
[Music]
you think that girls are lazy
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay
i'll pause it there
if i'm am i have i been shut down
am i banned
am i banned okay i'm buzzing it there
because i don't want you all to watch it
here because it does them no good if you
watch that here there is a link in the
description that will take you right to
that animation you can go check it out
feel free to do it now
i'm still here okay good they haven't
shut me down anyway they they put in
like a year's worth of work into that
animation i think i did the voice for
that like way back in
maybe
may of last year it was a while ago uh
so that's been in the works for a while
i meant to promote it when it was going
to premiere uh like had some things come
up wasn't able to do it got busy was
doing the sound mix so go check it out
link is in the description
leave it a like
definitely do that help promote it like
i think like still matter in this
universe of youtube that we are in uh
leave a comment of your favorite part
just like uh really engage it because a
lot of people should see that it's just
i mean i love those guys they're
fantastically talented people and uh
just like the work that they've put into
that and everything that they do and and
helping out with like my show
it's just like stupendous and you know
if you watched heist
you know one of the reasons why uh you
love yancey so much is because they did
the song for that i don't know if enough
people know that they did the song
i don't want to be free they did that
one they made it all of it and so if you
have anyone to thank for that
you got to thank them because just one
of the one of the benefits of doing
youtube for as long as i have is that
like i have had the privilege to work
with incredibly talented people and i am
lucky enough that whenever i have a
crazy idea they are more than happy to
help me with my crazy ideas uh so
definitely show them all the love in the
world if you haven't checked out shmo
yoho's
uh videos before they're a music-based
channel they do a lot of auto-tune
things they they make parodies of things
they make a lot of original songs too so
go check those out
and just send them
all the love in the world and if you
haven't seen uh
i don't want to be free and heist
you go
click on the first because if you didn't
know a heist with markiplier is a choose
your own adventure it is
um
i don't think that's a spoiler but if
you want to find that and you haven't
seen it yet
or you haven't visited in a while you
have to click on the first video i
believe you go out guns blazing get the
helicopter and then recruit
uh the prisoners rally the prisoners
that's what it is you'll get there if
you haven't visited yancey in a while
how dare you
how
dare you
anyway
it's uh
yeah it's really cool they're incredible
and there are a ton of other people that
have also helped out with space
that i won't spoil
um because
well
you'll just have to watch the show then
so
go check that out link is in the
description it's the top line one it's i
believe the description says the
animation that i was mentioning is it
down there is it down there
oh yeah it's not my birthday is it still
that thumbnail i thought i changed that
i thought i'd change it to this image
here i thought it was
[Music]
yeah for some reason i don't know why
but whenever i do the like instant
stream on youtube it defaults to that
thumbnail and i've tried to change it
for a while it is just that is just a
really sticky thumbnail
i don't know i have no idea um
but yeah so give them all the love in
the world link is in the description it
is that's the image you saw on the
notification then why is it changed back
to the birthday one
i don't know something about youtube in
their their streaming is like very uh
very sticky yeah but uh that's all i'll
say about
space for now
just look forward
i just can't wait i just can't wait i
can't wait for you guys to see
it it's gonna be really fun it's gonna
be really really fun
the thumbnail is sticky that's all it is
yeah the notification was birthday when
youtube please
yeah um okay so other than that
there's something else that i would like
to talk about that is very important now
listen closely because i'm not gonna
repeat myself on this one you have to
pay very very close attention this is
it's actually something that's very near
and dear to my heart
that uh
oh my light my light's wrong why did
that one go
sorry i'll tell you in just a second i i
just
this is such an important thing i don't
want anything distracting from it so
just hold on because
i mean it's more of a confession really
than anything and you know i
i know a lot of you will
probably think different on me after you
hear what i have to say
you know it's never easy it's never easy
coming clean you know it's never easy
to uh
say things like this out loud so
you know
i'm getting getting choked up just
thinking about it because
uh you know it's too important to give
all this preamble for it's too important
so
just be sure to listen closely to my
words
as i say them as i speak them as i utter
them with my mouth as i form sounds into
coherent
syllables and consonants
and vowels
i just remember you know keep in mind
that uh i am human i'm human i am human
at the base of it i am just me i am
myself i am my own person i am
who i am
at my core and i don't think i've
changed
maybe i have maybe i'll leave that to
you to judge me after i give you this
information after i declare it to you
after i confide in you the secrets in my
soul
we all have secrets in our soul and i
think
that
opening up that soul to
deliver the message to others is
the hardest thing that we have ever
done sometimes you know
the hardest thing
and now when i say these words to you
when i tell you these secrets when i
bear my soul to you i want you to take
them in
understand them
nurture them cherish them
process them analyze them if you will
break them down
don't misunderstand them
that's what's important
i'm telling you now
i'm about to say
all right fine
i have a new podcast with tyler
we mentioned it in a video that we did
for the super bowl but uh i have a new
podcast with tyler
and
and uh it's it's just like it's such a
fun
uh
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
are you shaking and crying right now are
you shaking and crying yeah no i got a
new podcast with tyler uh it's called go
my favorite sports team um and it's just
been a really fun adventure i haven't
been able to do something with tyler
uh for a very long time if you guys
don't know tyler who are you and where
have you been um but tyler is one of my
oldest friends uh we've known each other
since fourth grade
he will say third grade that is
impossible
i was not in the same school as him when
i was in third grade so it doesn't make
any sense for him to say that we met
when we were in third grade it's
illogical right it doesn't make any
sense um
but uh
for now we will just say uh but one of
the ways that we first met was because
we were on
the milford wrestling team we wrestled
together and we uh we kind of bonded
through that we we met through that and
it's just one of those things that has
kind of
bridged our lives now me i'm not a
sports guy actually let me play you
something i i have uh there's a link in
the description to the podcast
on spotify it's available also apple
podcasts and a few other places google
podcasts and stuff like that um but let
me uh
uh
here it is i should have had this up and
ready but i'm not a professional
anything uh but
the podcast is called go my favorite
sports team and it is a sports podcast
but i am not a sports guy i don't
even know sports i like so
the the beauty of it is it's for people
that like sports and also it's for
people that don't like sports because
tyler and i we bonded through sports but
i don't like sports well i'm starting to
like sports i'm starting to understand
it right because understanding is like
the basis of like appreciating something
um
and and
i didn't realize how
stupid i was
let me just play this let me play this
hang on one second
i think it is i don't
here we go
sports very good hi i'm mark i don't
know sports very good i've i've dabbled
i'm a dabbler but tyler's here hi my
name is tyler scheid i have a master's
degree in sport administration and i
love sports do you want to learn about
sports figure out the rules or get a
greater understanding of sports that are
happening in our daily lives this is the
podcast for you because i'm an idiot and
tyler needs to explain things very
slowly to me it's this many periods or
this many quarters or whatever which i
don't know why i said this many quarters
quarters is obviously for but like the
basis understanding of the game
oh
my god
oh
that makes sense okay continue
in this podcast we cover the major
sports and even some of the minor sports
so that you can learn and figure out
what's going on in the sports world
today we'll be discovering what sports
means to people how sports affect our
lives the lives of people that play
sports and everything that could be a
resultant of decisions that attribute
themselves towards sports as didn't make
sense your center is like your big tall
big guy like think of shaquille o'neal
i'm thinking about him all the time man
you don't even need to tell me to think
about shaquille o'neal he's in the back
of my mind but you know who shaq is
yes i know why are you looking at me
like that i know
i know he's in those uh
spicy hot commercials all the time you
gotta get spices
we won't just be talking about sports
we'll also be talking about how sports
stretch and impact our daily lives
whether it's political economic or
beyond if this sounds like the podcast
for you take a listen you're listening
to it right now it's too late
you're trapped you're trapped you're in
the game you're in the game now and you
just lost the game
all right uh enough of this go listen to
an episode okay so that was the trailer
for uh the podcast uh if you like
distractible i think you'll like this
one because again it's just like me
bullshitting with my friends um but i'm
also very happy to be able to do
something with tyler tyler
he's such a good guy and it's it's just
like super unfortunate because we've all
been impacted by like covet and and
whatnot but he he more than most because
he is immunocompromised if you don't
know tyler he had a uh kidney transplant
when he was
20 20. i can't remember exactly how old
he was but uh so he has a transplant
which usually means that you have to
take medication that suppresses your
immune system so he has had to be super
isolated and very careful so which means
that he hasn't been able to get out much
so finally you know you know up until
recently he's been able to get out more
and uh you know do more things and i'm
very happy that he's been able to do
that um
and now we're finally able to work on
this because i one of the unfortunate
things about me always wanting to do
things is because i i sometimes bulldoze
through life without ever realizing like
you know that what i'm doing or and and
i'm a terrible friend because like i'm
bad at responding to texts i'm bad at
keeping up with people all this stuff uh
so to have something regular that tyler
and i can talk about that he is
an expert on right he is not just
knowledgeable about sports tyler has a
master's degree
in sport administration he
knows sports he's written papers on
sport and what's beautiful is i am the
opposite of that i know next to nothing
about sports i think in the back of my
mind i kind of knew the principle
between quarters and being one two three
four
quarters of a hole
but it just like this kind of stuff
doesn't dawn on me
so it's so fun to be able to talk about
something that i don't know
from someone that knows it incredibly
that i have this like
really long history with and yet it's a
part of his life that is such a huge
part of his life that i know next to
nothing about i've always surface level
been like oh he's a sports guy i didn't
know the nuance of which he knows things
so what's great about the podcast um is
that
i just get to be an idiot the whole time
whereas distractible i'm one-third of a
whole idiot between bob wade and i
with tyler and i i am the whole idiot
and i just get to be stupid
he had me he had me in the most recent
episode we were talking about the winter
olympics um and it was just him naming
winter olympic events and me trying to
guess what the hell it was and there's
one i forget what the name of it but if
you haven't heard of this event
wait it's the biathlon the winter
biathlon right so i told you what is the
winter biathlon write in the comments if
you don't know what it is if you know
what it is please step aside if you
don't know what the winter biathlon is
write in the comments what you think the
winter biathlon would be because you
would be wrong
you would be wrong
i want to see what do you guys get no
idea now guess guess this is where you
guess use your deductive reasoning and
guess
shaking and crying
yeah yeah it's it's it's winter shaking
and crying because you got left out
you're dropped via parachute into the
siberian wilderness
no you're all wrong you're all wrong
it's cross-country skiing
and shooting
which i do
i don't understand
i don't understand how that happened but
we go over this in the podcast so that's
that's what the podcast is about if
you're if you're expecting this podcast
to be like a breakdown of the game that
just happened last night it's not what
it's about it's it's kind of just a
place to
understand why people care about sports
so much and what sports even is and how
it ties into like the greater
understanding of the human condition and
how people can be yeah it's
cross-country skiing
and shooting did you say you were just
skiing and shooting right now i don't
think you are i don't i'm calling
[ __ ] on that one if you're watching
this stream and you are skiing and
shooting please turn the stream off and
pay attention to where you are skiing
and what you are shooting
uh you can't be distracted with this
right now maybe if you listen to the
podcast because it's an audio thing you
can do that
and please pay attention to where you're
going
yeah so it's go after a little ski shoot
yo shooty ski bang bang
mountain boom you know you ever want
that so
that's kind of like what we do on the
podcast so if you are not a sports fan
this podcast is still for you because
number one it's just me and tyler we're
shooting the [ __ ] and we like we have
such a history that like
man tyler just makes me laugh and and
i'm always happy when i can make tyler
laugh and sometimes like uh it's so
funny because i'll tell it obviously a
joke
and he
will just glaze right over it as if i
was he's so used to my [ __ ]
that it doesn't phase him anymore like
so i have to try to top myself in the
ridiculous [ __ ] that i'll say
on this on this podcast to try to get
him to laugh because god he is the best
laugh i i
i try my goal in every episode is to get
him to goose laugh because if you've
watched videos with tyler before or
streams with tyler before he he has he
has the best laugh
but if you get him to laugh hard enough
he will literally not be able to stop
and he will turn into a goose like
literally he has
i can't even do it
like i don't even know how it does it
but he he might die laughing he he's
probably the only human being that i
actually can i'm concerned about him
dying laughing because
he he on a streamer at one time we got
him to laugh
and it's just like he didn't stop
laughing for five minutes and by the end
of it he wasn't breathing so he was just
like he literally was to the point after
like he was just
and laughing
like just for
just for uh
just for five minutes and we were very
concerned but that's my goal now is just
like i i just want to get i just want to
get him left like that every time so
it's it's a very fun podcast link is in
the description to the spotify link you
can search for it obviously on apple
podcast it's go my favorite for sports
team go exclamation my favorite sports
team
i uh having a ton of fun with that so
please check that out it's something
that uh like i'm very proud of but also
i'm very proud because like you know
with distractible it's it's like
it's a shared thing between bob wade and
i and now i finally get uh to have tyler
have this thing that is as much his as
it is mine that's that's one of my
favorite things to do is
make these things
uh where my friends can really shine and
also they don't have to be
you know and friends you know i mean
because like i did the tour uh the your
welcome tour and and every panel i had
was like markiplier and friends you know
and i hate i hate that because my
friends are so talented and that's
what's beautiful about say in space with
markiplier my name is on it but
the friends that have joined me on it
are so incredibly talented so for any
opportunity for them to really shine in
their element and showcase what they can
do
is beautiful to me and so with this one
like if if you listen to the podcast not
only are you supporting me but you're
supporting tyler and really allowing him
to shine and really like have his moment
there there's a a subreddit as well if
you guys want to post memes and stuff
there's a subreddit for distractible
there's also a subreddit for
go my favorite sports team i believe
it's
gmf gm
fst reddit.com
gmfst
i believe that's it um
so no the podcast is free you don't
why do everyone think this why does
everyone think this the podcast is free
it's free
it's free
it's free no no no no it doesn't cost
money no literally just listening is
supporting that's it
podcast free there's still people that
think distractable costs money for some
reason it's free
heist with markiplier free in space with
markiplier
free
is free
it doesn't cost no money
it's free
no no podcast pay
free
is
free
like my videos
ad supported ad and what's beautiful is
like i don't know how we've gotten away
with it because on distractible if
you've listened to it obviously we do
ads but we do them
our version of ads and we are so
[ __ ] in our ads and because we try
to make it funny right we tr we're like
why would people just listen to this dry
ass read of buy x product at link.com
you know why can we just have fun with
it we actually spend more time
recording the ads than we do recording
the actual episode and we talked about
this recently on an episode where we
hope uh maybe it was that live stream
where we hope we can just like release
the uncut
commercials that we did it's just like
totally [ __ ] it's too expensive how
is free too expensive but uh so tyler
and i get to do that as well and no
one's called us out on it yet so
it's just like uh
it's just this kind of like
really crazy thing that these companies
are sponsoring us and they don't call us
out on i mean uh literally
when we're i forget what company we're
doing it for but i was talking about how
like i was trying to compete with them
by having a catapult that shot food at
your house
and they didn't call us out for it
we did a commercial where someone got
murdered in it
literally and no one calls us out on it
so it's it's very very fun we really
really enjoy it um so check it out it is
free you
no money link is in the description
below it's uh it's right below the
animation link uh that one links to
spotify but it's also available on apple
podcast google podcast all the other
things
uh so definitely
free now that's a scam
it's free i don't know what to tell you
it's free
you don't need it if you don't like one
service that's on another service
you just
no free
you want a refund done
it's there you go
it's done you want two refunds bam there
you go
you want three boom boom boom free
i do i i literally every time that i
mentioned distractible people are like
oh man i would love to listen to it but
i can't afford it say i
why
how are you watching the stream if your
excuses like you don't even have a
device to do it how are you watching the
stream how do you even know what i'm
saying how do you watch my videos it's
free
too expensive can't afford free
yeah three free refunds excuses
yeah oh the grubhub trebuchet that's
right
that was it wasn't a catapult it was a
trebuchet i forgot
yeah it's it's free
it's free link in the description it's
free
yeah but definitely listen to it because
number one i think it's a fun time and
like it's just like i really like doing
these things because it's it's like no
more work than normal video is you know
you know in my videos i record for
i i try to base it like i'll record for
an hour per video that's kind of like my
benchmark and like just being able to do
that with my friends because we do
videos together of course but just being
able to like shoot the [ __ ] we're not
doing anything but just like trying to
make each other laugh ah it's like god
that's fun
that's so fun i'm so lucky to be able to
do that
so
sounds like way too much
it's the same cost as breathing i don't
know well okay maybe
no no that's not even a good because i
was going to say maybe the data cost but
i'm like no it's audio you're watching a
live stream i'm shooting megabytes of
data at you
a podcast is
i think it's 192 kilobytes it's tiny by
comparison the amount of data between
this live stream and that podcast has
been surpassed already since i started
talking about it boom more data more
data saving that doesn't even cost
no it's it's what can i do what can i do
no definitely check it out link is in
the description it is go my favorite
sports team you have to say go like that
if you don't say go like that you are
not saying the right name it is go
my favorite sports team
it's pretty expensive though
i don't know what to tell you i don't
know i don't know what to say too much
data
it's too free i see i see what it is
it's too free you don't trust it you
don't trust it i get that but it's free
i'm telling you it's not too free it's
not not enough free it's just the right
amount of free you get what i'm saying
it's like right there in the middle you
know how like you know you got this band
of like oh it's too expensive oh it's
two free it's right there i get it
i understand what you're saying you were
listening to i don't want to be free
from shmo yoho from a heist with
markiplier you don't want it to be free
okay
i've got a different system for you
i will give you a different link that
will have you
send me a hundred dollars and then you
can listen to it then it's not too free
right everybody wins i see you have a
selective taste i'll give you the deluxe
edition of the podcast
that has a slightly different cover art
for the nominal price of a hundred
dollars in fact in fact i'll let you
pre-order this amazing service at a
discount of a hundred and ten dollars
and then you will get two special icons
when that pre-order comes to fruition in
a year
how's that sound now that's capitalism
baby now that's capitalism
i'll make an nft
no it's free
see
it's free for some
but not for everyone right okay
you got it
too expensive
you drive a hard bargain
listen you're a shrewd customer and i
appreciate that frugal tell you what
you order in the next 10 minutes i'll
knock 50
off that bad boy you can get that deluxe
edition for a hundred and sixty dollars
sound fair deal shake my hand deal's
done
deal's done the deal's done
it's just that the tick tock for the
credit card
anyway
so also distract oh also this was a
concern that people had distractible is
not stopping so that i can do go my
favorite go my favorite sports team
it is
i'm doing them both
at the same time i know it sounds crazy
but uh
you know how i can talk for hours and
never get tired
i'm just turning that into a podcast
right turning it into a podcast
anyway can you pay in milk i will take
milk
i take any form of payment rocks
dirt
air that you kind of waft in my general
direction just start just put your hand
out your window
and wherever you think i am in the world
just kind of push
in that way and that'll be the payment
and i will get that thank you oh it's
just awesome right now thank you very
much
yeah
so uh link to that is in the description
go my favorite sports team check it out
and yes distractible is still going to
happen
there's no reason why it would not i
love doing that i'm super happy with
that yeah and also just uh uh if you if
you don't know tyler go check him out he
is uh he's very active on twitter he's
doing a lot of tick tocks these days um
apocalypto underscore 12. if you follow
him on twitter uh tweet on him if you
listen like literally and i mean this
genuinely when you listen to the podcast
let him know what you think of it like
it would mean a lot to him like and i
know because uh he's like i'm not saying
like he's
only
thrives on like positive feedback he's
he's he's a grown-up he's he's a big boy
he'd be fine but it would mean a lot to
him to know that people are really
enjoying it so go listen to an episode
there's an episode where we talk about
like i asked tyler a bunch of stupid
questions about sports that's the first
episode about what sports is the truth
of sports we talk about the nfl which uh
i'm going to have that nfl episode
turned into an animation because
it's just like i didn't realize how
stupid i was about football and
understanding it uh and i didn't know
what special teams were i thought it was
special ops and all that stuff
um but go check that out uh just
there's a ton of things that you could
see in that we did winter olympics and
then we got more podcast episodes coming
out those come out every thursday uh and
when you listen to an episode let tyler
know what you think i i mean this
sincerely like let him know what you
think if you enjoyed the podcast he
would love to hear that and i would love
for him to know that he is making
something really really cool we actually
thought of this idea
while we were filming space right so we
were we we thought of it then uh it was
a late night and we were sitting around
waiting for lighting to go set up
whatever and you know we were talking
about something that and i i always knew
that i wanted to do something with tyler
and just tyler um and we came up with
this idea and it was just like one of
those moments where
you know
it was set as a joke
and then we you know it's like ah yeah
we could do a podcast where you i don't
know anything about sports and you just
tell me and i'd be an idiot back and
we're just we laugh and then we just
wait a minute
that's a good idea and then we just
rolled with it you know that's always
how the best ideas get formed
so
yes
tell him what you think it would mean a
lot to him and go check out his other
stuff he's got tick-tock apocalypto
underscore 12. he's a good dude
if you want to check out some of the
earliest videos that we've done together
i think
actually for some reason i think um
mark on the player most disgusting
popsicle
isn't that it yeah that's right we made
popsicles out of random both 9.5 million
views damn well he's this is one of the
earliest videos that he was in
um
and just
uh what but am i looking for i am a
professional i know what i'm doing i
know what i'm doing i know what i'm
doing i know what i'm doing
yeah hello everybody my name is
markiplier and this is tyler say hi
if you're wondering why we're wearing
gloves or wondering why there's a block
of dry ass right in front of us we're
about to do a challenge
challenge shut the [ __ ]
yeah that's our friend that's our
friendship
god we've known each other for a long
time he actually um he came out
to
la to work
uh with me on videos like he that's the
whole reason he came out because he
trusted me enough to be like and i
didn't know what the [ __ ] i was doing at
that time um but you want to know why a
date with markiplier happened it's
because he came out i mean obviously
there were other people helping out but
he was just like
i wouldn't have been able to do any of
that stuff unless i had the support of
my friends who are extremely talented
people you know
that video is called uh
tartar sauce popsicle that's what it is
um
and so
having
[Music]
like
these people
to support me and and help with these
ideas you know
who killed markiplier wouldn't have
happened you know markiplier tv wouldn't
have happened you know it's it's all of
these things that i'm making now and
obviously he was helping with space you
know it's uh
it's kind of this
like it's something that i can't really
repay and it's something that i i guess
in a way i don't need to repay in so
many like concrete terms but
i i've had the privilege of seeing like
my friends flourish in terms of their
their own confidence and talents and
their abilities and to see like how
these people have progressed
uh you know it's just like i'm
i'm so proud of them you know i'm just
proud of them and i'm proud of what
they've done and i'm proud of tyler and
and to to know that we're still like
making stuff together and we we still
have something and now now he has
something that has his name on it you
know it's not just him helping me with
my stuff it's it's us worth in working
together on something that we share like
that's
that's what really makes
all this very very special like that's
what makes
making things on youtube or wherever
very special to me because
like
i'm
[Music]
i'm just extremely fortunate to be able
to do what i do
and i know
that there are people that are more
talented than me there there are people
that know more especially in like
different fields like with tyler and
sports he is
his level of knowledge compared to my
own is
orders of magnitude
more
i mean anything would be when your
knowledge is zero right but but it's
just like i love seeing how far my
friends have come in terms of their own
ability you know i you know bob has
always been one of the funniest people
like i've ever met he is just and you
would all agree he is just the funniest
guy you know and uh but to see him like
go from just
you know
like
being a hilarious friend to
pretty much leading carrying a podcast
actually no i can't even say that
because wade as well just like
so [ __ ] funny and just his his
insanity but his witty insanity is crazy
to me it's it's like just to see where
they've come
you know it's just like ah it's it's
beautiful i love them and i'm so proud
of them and i'm just so happy and ethan
too you know ethan like he he's always
been talented and he's always been
insane but just like doing luna honest
with him like seeing him grow as a
creator and stuff like that and you know
it's just like it's beautiful
i love seeing it and other youtubers
that i've met
uh over the years just
and i i
what's fascinating about that and what's
universal and kind of like the
fundamental thing behind
seeing this is
everyone has
something
everyone does and if they don't know it
yet they just haven't had the chance to
nurture that side of it everyone
is creative i believe humans in general
are very creative we are all creative we
all have the power to create we all like
this spark inside of us and it's just
like some of us just don't get the
chance to really
nurture that and stoke the fire of
creativity inside of us and so
i've been very lucky that i've had
the chance to do it you know i made the
chance for myself and you know it wasn't
that anyone needed to hand it to me or
hand it to my friends or anything like
that but like
everyone
has it
and if you don't have the situation
where someone can help you nurture it
like you really gotta dive into yourself
and find the willpower to push for it
and it's not easy it's not easy i i'm
coming up on my 10 year
anniversary
of doing youtube
and 10
years of doing youtube is a long time to
do anything but also in the grand scheme
of my life it's not that long
and
you know
going from the first video that i made
to where i am right now
i'm
well you know i'm proud of myself you
know i'm proud of what i've done and i'm
proud of where i've come and you know
i'm
not proud of where i've come that's not
what i meant to say that doesn't make
any sense at all i'm proud of where i've
come from
that's more accurate
god i haven't gotten any better since i
started this i don't know what the hell
i'm talking about 10 years later but i'm
just very excited
that i'm at a point where i've been
doing this for 10 years and yet i still
have this drive to make things
what i make kind of like evolves but
also a lot of what i make hasn't really
changed i'm still
doing let's plays and i try to elevate
it here and there and you know that that
varies depending on how much time i have
working on these other things but also
it's just like
i don't know
it's really cool
i've always been very self-reflective
you know i i i has a statement to
hesitate to say that i'm nostalgic
um but i do look back and where i've
come from and i talk about this a lot
where people are very self-critical
about the things that i've made in the
past they've made in the past i am not
that way i'm really not i look back at
like the earliest sketch that i've done
and you know uh the fall of slenderman
the first appearance of wharf stash and
i can look back at that and i can from a
technical perspective say that there's
an incredible number of things wrong
with that video and there's incredible
number of things that i would have done
differently had i known but at the same
time i'm still proud of that i'm still
very proud of the videos that i made
when i first started just as much as i'm
i'm proud of the things that i'm making
now and i think that's an important
perspective for anyone that's creative
is is the things that you made when you
first started out are not bad
they are going to be bad
and there's a distinction there i'm
using the same word but you have to
understand
they're not bad
they're just the best that you could do
at that time so long as you did the best
that you could do
they're not bad in context
they're bad in retrospect technically
but i put everything into that i put
everything into the videos that i make
from them
i don't put everything into every video
i make but when i make something that i
really want to tell i push myself to the
absolute limit of what i can do and i do
that every time
and i in 10 years from now i might if
i'm still alive uh 10 years from now i
might look back on space to be like wow
i could have done so many different
things and even now look i'm doing the
sound systems like i wish i had done
this i wish i had done that but that
doesn't matter it's not regrets it's
just things you'll take into the future
you know it's just lessons that's it
that's all it's about you know
you know
happy birthday
thank you thank you it is my birthday
hey thank you guys so much really
appreciate your beer celebrating my
birthday whoa big birthday that it is i
and you know given that it is my
birthday i have a small request you know
it's my birthday present from you to me
thank you for the birthday wishes hey
because it's my birthday
go down that description check out the
link to go my favorite sports team
it's a podcast with tyler it's totally
free it would mean a lot
for me on my birthday which it
definitely is
if you listen to that it would mean the
world to me it would mean the world to
me it's totally free hey thank you it's
your birthday present from you to me and
i appreciate that i give appreciation
for me to you
thank you
thank you
thank you
ah man
june i don't know that word i don't know
what you're talking about that doesn't
make any sense to me
no
it's my birthday even if it sounds too
expensive to listen to that free podcast
through the link in the description
below
it's my birthday come on aren't i worth
it aren't i worth it i think i'm a
little worth it i think i'm just a
little worth it you know i'm a little
worth it
come on
yeah
all right anyway
that's all for now i'm to get out of
here thank you guys so much for joining
me for this uh nothing strange happening
here stream
i think we talked about everything that
i wanted to talk about uh links are in
the description if you want to check
them out thank you so much for stopping
by
uh and if you do listen
definitely let tyler know what you
thought
because he would appreciate that and i
would appreciate that
and uh also definitely check out the
animation from schmoyoho actually i'm
gonna look right now
look right now i'm looking looking for
looking for comments
looking for comments okay all right
gloria yeah that's good brian jones yeah
monkey random okay all right asher
amelia this is great this is good you
guys are checking it out you guys are
doing it but there could be more could
be more i could have read your name just
now but you did did you did you go leave
a comment on that did you go listen to
the pocket
no i appreciate it but definitely check
that out because they put in a ton of
work into that leave a like on it it's
fantastic
oh
i apologize
i apologize but there's only i only see
there's only been about 4 000 new likes
since last i mentioned that go to link
in the description check it out don't
wait you can do it
you can do it take a little bit of time
it's a it's a three minute video it's a
four minute video it's a four minute
fully animated music video that you will
love four minutes
go check it out link in the description
do it right now
and then
the link just below that
podcast
go my favorite sports team with tyler
check it out don't wait it's my birthday
you wouldn't want to disappoint me on my
birthday didn't you wouldn't you didn't
wouldn't you
lose his face you wouldn't want to
disappoint his face
okay i'm gonna go alright bye
farewell have a good day